[Musik]
das ganze hopp hopp
ehrenzug schon
fressen
[Musik]
das ganze recht Shop
Jahren
33 zum feierlichen Festtag angetreten
vielen Dank für die Meldung mit dem
Festakt beginnen
[Musik]
das ganze hopp hopp
ehrenzug schon
[Musik]
beim Fuß
das ganze Parade Ruth
das ganze habt
ehrenzug schon
[Musik]
ehrenzug pressentiert
Flagge hissen
das ganze rechts Shop
[Musik]
das ganze
schon
[Musik]
beim Fuß
das ganze Parade gut
auch diesmal dürfen wir eine große
Anzahl von Ehrengäste in unsere Mitte
begrüßen und hier suche der am
Verständnis dass wenn der Gebote den
Zeit natürlich nicht alle nennen können
ich begrüße die vom Bundesministerin für
Landesverteidigung Magister Claudia
Tanner
in Vertretung der Landeshauptfrau von
Niederösterreich und auch als Vertreter
des Niederdeutschen Landtages darf den
Abgeordneten zum niederösterreichischen
Landtag und Bürgermeister der Garnison
statt Korneuburg Christian Gepp den
landeshauptverstellvertreter Franz
Schnabel und die Abgeordneten
zumindestischen Landtag vor Ina Aigner
und Jürgen Handler in unsere Mitte
begrüßen
es freut uns stellvertretend für alle
ressortangehörigen den kabinettchef des
Ressorts Generalmajor Magister Rudolf
Striedinger und in Vertretung des
Militärkommandanten von Niederösterreich
Oberst Michael Lippert bei uns
willkommen zu heißen
willkommen in unserer Mitte dem
stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden des
Zentralausschusses
und den Vorsitzenden
Markus Gruber
ein herzliches Grüß Gott den Vertretern
der Geistlichkeit für die katholische
militärpfarre militär-
dr Karl Reinhard Trauner
Stellvertretung für alle
Blaulichtorganisationen ein
kameradschaftliches willkommen
Landespolizeidirektor Generalmajor Franz
Popp landesfeuerwehrrat Wilfried Kargl
und in Vertretung des
bezirkspolizeikommandanten Chefinspektor
Alois Schneid
für alle Anwesenden bezirkshauptleute
darf ich stellvertretend die
bezirkshauptfrau des Bezirks Korneuburg
wirkliche dr Waltraud Müller Teufel
begrüßen
es freut uns besonders im Bürgermeister
der Gemeinde Gerasdorf Herr Magister
Alexander Wolters und den Hausherrn der
Marktgemeinde Hagenbrunn Bürgermeister
Michael oberschild begrüßen zu dürfen
vom Bundesministerium für Inneres
begrüße ich ein Günter thiemall und vom
Bundesministerium für Digitalisierung
und Wirtschaftsstandort Herrn
Diplomingenieur Karl lebe da
für alle ressouren gehören im Ruhestand
begrüße ich respektvoll general in Ruhe
Karl
abschließend darf ich alle Angehörigen
und Gäste begrüßen danke dass Sie in
diesem für die Rekruten so wichtigen Tag
dieser Veranstaltung den würdigen Rahmen
geben ich ersuche nun den Bürgermeister
der Marktgemeinde Hagenbrunn herr
Michael oberschwellung seine Grußworte
sehr geschätzte Frau Bundesministerin
hochverehrte militärische Geistlichkeit
sehr geehrter Herr Landeshauptfrau
Stellvertreter geschätzter Herr
Landtagsabgeordneter und
bürgermeisterkollege Herr
Landespolizeidirektor Frau
bezirkshauptfrau verehrte und Festgäste
Liebe Anzüge lobende Rekruten
Hagenbrunn war bereits vor vielen Jahren
einmal Schauplatz einer Angelobung des
österreichischen Bundesheeres mit dem
2017/2017 eröffneten Dorfplatz können
wir aber nunmehr eine noch bessere
Location für solch eine Veranstaltung
bieten ich freue mich daher sehr über
diese Möglichkeit und darf alle in
Hagenbrunn sehr herzlich willkommen
heißen
als 2013 eine Volksbefragung zu
Wehrpflicht abgehalten wurde konnte ich
mir eigentlich nichts anderes als eine
Beibehaltung der Freiwilligkeit
vorstellen ich glaube dass sie mir meine
geschätzten Damen und Herren alle recht
geben werden dass das österreichische
bundesheeran unverzichtbarer Bestandteil
unserer Gesellschaft ist denken wir an
die sich in den letzten Jahren häufenden
Naturkatastrophen die ohne den großen
Einsatz der Soldatinnen und Soldaten nur
schwer bewältigbar wären
dass wir das Bundesheer aber einmal zu
einer Bewältigung der größten
Gesundheitskrise des letzten
Jahrhunderts benötigen war bis vor noch
nicht allzu langer Zeit undenkbar auch
Hagenbrunn war in seinem Betriebsgebiet
an der Brünnerstraße im Paket verteilt
sind und der österreichischen Post
massiv von Corona betroffen
hier hat das Abwehrzentrum ABC
Abwehrzentrum Korneuburg perfekte Arbeit
bei der Desinfektion und auch bei der
aufrechte Erhaltung des Betriebes
geleistet dabei durfte ich den
Kommandanten dieser Einheit Herrn Oberst
Magister Jürgen schlechter kennen und
schätzen lernen lieber Herr Oberst ich
darf mich seitens der Marktgemeinde
Hagenbrunn nochmals sehr herzlich bei
dir für diese hervorragende Arbeit
bedanken
aber auch den Bereich der militärischen
Landesverteidigung sollten wir in
Zukunft ausreichend Augenmerk schenken
obwohl wir Gott sei Dank in einem
friedlichen Umfeld leben dürfen dies
alles spricht für unser Bundesheer und
deshalb darf ich für die Zukunft viel
Freude und Erfolg bei der Bewältigung
dieser hohen Anforderung wünschen
sie hören jetzt einen Koral und im
Anschluss die Worte der Geistlichkeit
danach spielt die Militärmusik
Niederösterreich den traditionsmarsch
des arbeitserarbeitszentrums mutig und
hilfsbereit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Bundesminister
Herr Landeshauptfrau Stellvertreter Herr
Generalmajor Herr Oberst
stellvertretender Militärkommandant Herr
oberstkommandantes abc-abwehrzentrums
Soldaten aller Dienstgrade Werte
Ehrengäste sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
was hat ein Pfarrer hier beim Militär zu
tun mit Euch liebe Anzüge lobende
Rekruten hat das von ABC Abwehrzentrum
einrückungstermin Juli noch der
mittlerweile im Ruhestand befindliche
Militärdekan Alfred Weinlich als seine
letzte Freude sozusagen wie ich gehört
habe noch durchgenommen und mit Euch
liebe Rekruten vom jägerbad Lohn 33
haben wir das in der vergangenen Woche
erörtert
das Zweite Vatikanische Konzil diese
große Versammlung der katholischen
Bischöfe in den 1960er Jahren hat
festgehalten wer als Soldat im Dienst
des Vaterlandes steht betrachtet sich
als Diener der Freiheit der Völker und
als Garant und sicherer des Friedens
es ist die
ureigenste Aufgabe als Soldat und Sinn
und Ziel aller militärischen Ausbildung
im Ernstfall für Stabilität Sicherheit
und die Wahrung demokratischer
Strukturen zu sorgen sowie den Frieden
in dieser Dimension mit allen Mitteln zu
verteidigen
Liebe Rekruten ich wünsche euch für eure
Zeit im österreichischen Bundesheer so
oft wie möglich solche
sinnerfüllte Erfahrungen in Ausbildung
Übung und Einsatz dazu den Geist der
Kameradschaft in einer tiefen prägenden
Dimension über soziale Grenzen hinweg
die wir draußen in unserer zivilen
Gesellschaft oft aufgebaut haben
seid euch immer bewusst wofür ihr als
Soldaten steht nicht mit der Waffe in
der Hand gegen irgendetwas oder gegen
irgendjemanden sondern für etwas nämlich
für alles was das Leben in unserer
Gesellschaft in unserem Land in einer
positiven Art und Weise fördert für den
Frieden und für uns Menschen
Herr unser Gott du kannst und Stärke und
Stütze sein wir bieten für uns und
unsere Angehörigen das uns und Ihnen
nichts Böses zu stößt
lass uns nicht nur die Belastungen des
Dienstes sehen sondern auch die Freuden
die neuen Freundschaften die
Kameradschaft
wir wollen nach danken hier und heute
danken für dieses Land in dem wir leben
dürfen wir können danken für dieses Land
und auch für die Menschen die ihn im
wohnen
die heiße die wir bauen unsere Dörfer
und Städte dort soll die Hoffnung wohnen
und der Friede
und schenke denjenigen Frieden die im
Unfrieden leben
die Orte wo wir arbeiten in unseren
zivilen berufen aber auch als
Soldatinnen und Soldaten unsere Kasernen
unsere Übungsplätze sie sollen Orte sein
wo Menschen zuversichtlich in die
Zukunft schauen können sie sollen Orte
sein wo der Mensch etwas gilt und wo
auch das Geltung hat was er tut
die Kirchen und andere gottesdiensteten
unseres Landes sollen heilige Orte sein
steh uns bei wenn wir Unrecht abwehren
wehrlose schützen müssen
hilf uns wenn wir bedrohten oder
Geschädigten Menschen beistehen
gib uns Mut in schwierigen Situationen
das Gute und das Richtige zu tun gib uns
Tapferkeit wenn wir uns einsetzen müssen
gib uns Treue und Zusammenhalt wenn wir
bei einer guten Sache dienen
unser Ton und lassen soll ein Segen sein
für andere und wir bitten dazu um den
Segen
Herr segne alle Menschen und schenke der
Welt deinen Frieden Amen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es erfolgt nun als nächster
Programmpunkt die Rede des Kommandanten
des abcentrums Oberst des
generalstabsdienstes Magister Jürgen
schlechter und nach dem Marsch stolz auf
Niederösterreich spricht in Vertretung
der Landeshauptfrau von Niederösterreich
der Abgeordnete zum niederdeutschen
Landtag Christian geben
Bundesministerin
hohe Geistlichkeit
geschätzte ehren- und Festgäste liebe
Angehörige unserer Rekruten
geschätzte junge Soldaten die heute
angelobt werden
in wenigen Augenblicken
werden sie ein Versprechen abgeben
welches von großer Tragweite ist und im
Zentrum des heutigen Festaktes steht
sie versprechen unser Heimatland zu
verteidigen und wenn es zum Schutz ihrer
Familie ihrer Freunde oder der gesamten
Republik Österreich notwendig ist
jemanden das Leben zu nehmen und genauso
ihres zu geben
und ich bin überzeugt dass ein Mensch
kaum ein größeres Versprechen geben kann
als sie heute
und zum Glück hat es derzeit nicht den
Anschein als müssten sie dieses
Versprechen einlösen
dies kann sich aber kurzfristig ändern
wenn wir in die von Korneuburg noch rund
1600 km entfernte Ostukraine blicken
dann sehen wir ein Land in dem binnen
weniger Stunden ein Krieg begonnen hat
der bis heute bereits über Jahre
andauert und sich kein Ende absehen
lässt
Konflikte wie in Syrien Armenien und
Aserbaidschan in Israel und Palästina
bestätigen wie sehr unsere Welt nach wie
vor friedlos ist
in unserem Fachbereich der Abwehr von
atomaren biologischen und chemischen
Gefahren können wir uns ebenfalls nicht
in Sicherheit wiegen seit nur wenigen
Jahren ist der sogenannte INF-Vertrag
zur Vernichtung von Atomraketen die
gegen Europa wirksam werden können
aufgekündigt worden
vor 30 Jahren mühevoll politisch
verhandelt haben die Vereinigten Staaten
von Amerika und Russland diesen Beitrag
zu einem friedlichen Europa kurzerhand
aufgelöst und rüsten ihre Atomwaffen in
großen Umfang wieder auf andere Staaten
wie China und Pakistan und vermutlich
auch der Iran tun es den beiden gleich
die Abschreckungswirkung solcher Waffen
diese lediglich zu besitzen aber Gott
lob nicht zum Einsatz zu bringen dürfte
man mittlerweile auch nicht mehr
funktionieren
biologische Waffen in Form von
künstlichen Krankheitserregern oder
Genmanipulationen können heute ähnlich
wie mit 3D-Druckern in Laboren
hergestellt und leicht den Umlauf
gebracht werden und wir haben in den
letzten 15 Monaten am eigenen Schicksal
erlebt wie einschneidend diese
Auswirkungen auf unsere physische als
auch psychische und auch wirtschaftliche
Gesundheit und unser Zusammenleben sein
können
2018 hat in Großbritannien ein einziger
Tropfen meines chemischen Kampfstoffes
nahm es nobitschog zwei Menschen das
Leben gekostet und zwei weitere haben
dies nur knapp überlebt
sie geschätzte Soldaten werden dafür
ausgebildet diesen Gefahren zu begegnen
sie zu erkennen und Menschen Geräte und
Fahrzeuge wieder zu entstrahlen zu
enttäuschen und zu entgiften
dies zu tun ist der große Teil ihres
heutigen Gelöbnisses
ich als ihr Kommandant habe gemeinsam
mit meinem Team die Aufgabe sie für
solche Einsätze bestmöglich auszubilden
und vorzubereiten
wir machen das gerne und wir machen das
auch sehr gewissenhaft
wir sind dabei mit unserem Können in der
ABC Abwehr auch ganz vorne an der
Weltspitze und Sie können stolz sein mit
uns gemeinsam beim ABC Abwehrzentrum in
Korneuburg zu dienen
das wird diese Angelobung heute gerade
in Hagenbrunn feiern freut mich ganz
besonders vor über einem Jahr konnten
wir im postverteilerzentrum wenige
hundert Meter in diese Richtung entfernt
durch unser schnelles und effizientes
Eingreifen die paketverteilung für ganz
Österreich vor dem Kollaps retten
wir haben es anerkannt nach Partner und
mit dem Vertrauen der
Gesundheitsbehörden als auch der
Geschäftsleitung der Post die
Infrastruktur desinfiziert für die
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter
Hygienekonzepte erstellt und umgesetzt
die erste
Station betrieben
Pakete geschubst während sich die
Belegschaft größtenteils in Quarantäne
befand und wir haben danach das Personal
in die notwendigen Hygienemaßnahmen
eingeschult mit einem nachhaltigen
Erfolg den die Infektionen sind seitdem
sehr überschaubar
geschätzte Angehörige unserer jungen
Soldaten
wir Ausbilder und Kommandanten ihrer
Söhne können und wollen eine Erziehung
nicht ersetzen wir tun dafür tun dafür
unser Bestes damit die jungen Soldaten
gut ausgebildet werden um in den
schwierigen Aufgaben auch bestehen zu
können
viele Fertigkeiten wie etwa ein
Führerschein die die jungen Menschen
hier bei uns lernen erhöhen ihre
späteren Chancen beim Einstieg ins
Berufsleben
jungen Menschen ist vielleicht auf gar
nicht bewusst was es bedeutet in diesem
freien sicheren reichen und lebenswerten
Österreich aufzuwachsen
durch den Dienst beim Bundesheer und
durch den Einsatz unserer jungen
Soldaten für die österreichische
Bevölkerung leisten wir einen nicht
unerheblichen Beitrag dazu auf dieses
Heimatland auch stolz zu sein
einige verpflichten sich danach und
starten ein erfolgreicher berufliche
Karriere beim Bundesheer
aus langer Beobachtung und Erfahrung
kann ich Ihnen auch versichern dass es
einer Kameradschaft beim Bundesheer
oftmals eine Freundschaft und ein
Netzwerk fürs Leben wird
vor zwei Jahren habe ich im Rahmen einer
Angelobung in gerersdorf meiner Sorge
Ausdruck verliehen das ist mir
angesichts des damaligen Geldmangels
beim Bundesheer fast schon unmoralisch
erschien jungen Soldaten einen solchen
Eid abzuverlangen
heute hat sich einiges geändert wofür
mich bei Ihnen sehr geehrte Frau
Bundesministerin Tanner aufrichtig
bedanken möchte unsere Dächer in der
Kaserne werden wieder dicht gemacht in
den Unterkünften gibt es keinen Schimmel
mehr unsere Fahrzeugflotte wird laufend
erneuert und die Schutzausrüstung für
Soldatinnen und Soldaten signifikant
verbessert
vielen herzlichen Dank dafür dass das
Bundesheer bei den politisch
Verantwortlichen und der Bevölkerung
durch ihre Führung wieder den
Stellenwert bekommt den wir durch unsere
Leistungen wohl verdienen
die Soldatinnen und Soldaten werden die
österreichische Bevölkerung weiterhin
nicht im Stich lassen und unser Gelöbnis
einlösen
junge Rekruten
ich möchte mich bei Ihnen bedanken dass
Sie sich für den grundwertdienst
entschieden haben und Ihnen gleichzeitig
gratulieren denn ich bin überzeugt dass
sie diesen Dienst in einer der besten
Einheiten des Bundesheeres ableisten
ihre Erwartungshaltung mag vielleicht
von Filmen mit martialischen Helden und
immer während der Action geprägt sein
aber sie sind jetzt schon lange genug
bei uns um erkannt zu haben dass dies
nicht der Realität entspricht das Sinn
und Zweck des österreichischen
Bundesheeres und im Speziellen ihres
Dienstes besteht eben nicht darin bloß
Krieg zu spielen mit einem Actionfilm
sondern mich eingangs gesagt habe ihre
Freunde ihre Familie und die
österreichische Bevölkerung zu schützen
und sie tun dies in vielfältiger Art und
Weise
gleichzeitig lernen Sie vielfältige
Fähigkeiten wie die Einordnung als
einzelner in die Gemeinschaft das
Zurückstellen der Person hinter der
Sache und das gemeinsame Ziel
den persönlichen Verzicht und
Einschränkung in ihrer Privatsphäre in
ihrer Freizeit in ihrer Zeiteinteilung
und nicht zuletzt im sehr gering
verfügbaren sollt
sie lernen Selbstdisziplin Ordnung
Pünktlichkeit und Genauigkeit das
Ertragen außergewöhnlichen Situationen
und das Erkennen des Wertes der
Gemeinschaft für die Bewältigung von
Problemen
kurzkameradschaft
zusammenhelfen und kümmern um den
Schwachen und Solidarität mit Respekt
Solidarität und Respekt vor anderen
wenn Sie uns nach sechs Monaten wieder
verlassen dann gehen sie stolz aus ihrer
Kaserne hinaus in ihrer weiteres Leben
weil sie bei uns weit mehr erlebt haben
und gelernt haben als nur zu wissen wie
man ein Gewehr putzt
durch das Treuegelöbnis dass wir
Soldaten alle geleistet haben können wir
aufeinander zählen es ist ein
gemeinsames Fundament auf welchem der
höchst dekorierte general aber auch der
jüngste Rekrut steht
ich wünsche Ihnen in den noch vor ihnen
liegenden Wochen der Ausbildung auch
viel Freude
Herausforderung und
kameradschaftserlebnis und vor allem
auch einen unfallfreien Verlauf es leben
unsere anzugelobenden Rekruten es lebe
das österreichische Bundesheer
[Applaus]
[Musik]
zu Beginn möchte ich jene begrüßen die
heute im Mittelpunkt stehen die Rekruten
des österreichischen Bundesheeres den
wenigen Minuten angelobt werden mein
besonderer Gruß gilt dir Frau
Bundesminister allen ehren- und
Festgästen Damen und Herren des
österreichischen Bundesheeres sowie den
Familienangehörigen der Rekruten
ich darf Ihnen vorweg die besten Grüße
unserer Landeshauptfrau übermitteln
und bei einer Angelobung bezeichnet man
in Österreich die Verpflichtung zur
gesetzestreuen und gewissenhaften
Ausübung übertragener Funktionen mit
einer feierlichen Vereidigung dem
Gelöbnis das wird heute hier in
Hagenbrunn erfolgen wiederkommandant
schlechter schon erwähnt ist es aber
nicht mehr als das
junge Menschen leisten einen wichtigen
Dienst an und für die Gemeinschaft
Grundwehrdienst ist die Verbindung
Schnittstelle zwischen militär-
die Zeit wird sie liebe Rekruten positiv
prägen puncto Kameradschaft
und werden Inhalte mitnehmen für
späteres Leben
und es ist ein großer Tag für die
Familien liebe Eltern liebe Familie
diese jungen Menschen sind hier in
ausgezeichneten Händen und dass das
österreichische Bundesheer neben der
Ausbildung und der Einsatz Vorbereitung
alles leistet sehen wir immer öfters was
heute auch schon mehrmals erwähnt werden
wurde in Katastrophen einsetzen oder bei
der Bekämpfung der Pandemie wir brauchen
ein starkes österreichisches Bundesheer
das so bin ich mir sicher wird das auch
in der Bevölkerung so gesehen
Korneuburg als Standort der ABC
Abwehrzentrum hat eine lange und sehr
positive Geschichte mit ihrer Kaserne
und vor allem mit jenen die in dieser
Kaserne diese mit Leben erfüllen
auch wir können im Bezirk von einer
tollen Zusammenarbeit sprechen und das
drückt sich auch in Zahlen aus
über 150 Mann mit mehr als 2000
Manntagen waren im Bezirk Korneuburg
bisher während der Pandemie im Einsatz
kontaktracing bis hin zu Unterstützung
in den teszenden Testzentren wie
angesprochen auch beim
postverteilerzentrum oder Abwicklung von
massentestungen dazu kommt die intensive
Abstimmung durch die Fachleute des ABC
Abwehrzentrum mit den Gemeinden und der
Behörde dafür Frau Bundesminister ein
herzliches Dankeschön dass dies möglich
war und bei dir Kommandant Jürgen
schlechter ganz persönlich für alle
Kameraden des österreichischen
Bundesheeres mein und unser herzliches
Dankeschön ich wünsche Ihnen Werte
Rekruten ein spannendes und
kameradschaftliche Zeit im Rahmen des
Grundwehrdienstes und darf mich bei
allen die im österreichischen Bundesheer
aktiv sind ganz herzlich bedanken
sie hören nun die Ansprache der
Bundesministerin für Landesverteidigung
Magistra Claudia Tanner
sehr geehrter Herr
Landtagsabgeordnete in Vertretung
unserer Landeshauptfrau
sehr geehrter Herr Landeshauptfrau
Stellvertreter Herr Bürgermeister
oberschill Herr Bürgermeister der
Nachbargemeinde
hohe Geistlichkeit
Vertreter von Politik Verwaltung und
Blaulichtorganisationen
sehr geehrter Herr
ehemaliger Stabschef Generalstabschef
Stellvertreter lieber
Generalmajor Rudi stridinger
Kommandanten Soldatinnen und Soldaten
vor allem aber
sehr geehrte
Rekruten und auch an diejenigen
gerichtet die heute via Livestream bei
dieser Feier dabei sind
ich weiß nicht wie es Ihnen geht aber es
tut so unglaublich gut
wieder
beisammen zu sein an Orten wie diesen
in Momenten wie diesen die nicht nur
geprägt sind von der Bekämpfung der
Pandemie
die uns alle so sehr gefordert hat
auch die Polizei Herr Landespolizei
Kommandant
zahlreiche Assistenz Einsätze
Unterstützungsleistungen ja und der
Oberst schlechter das ABC
Abwehrzentrum das stand immer in der
ersten Reihe es stand dann in der ersten
Reihe wenn es darum ging die Arbeit zu
verteilen
tausende abertausende Arbeitsstunden im
Kampf gegen das Virus das
infektionsmaßnahmen die Mitwirkung beim
contactracing die Testungen auch der
Bevölkerung die auch schon angesprochen
worden sind ja und die Unterstützung für
das
postverteilerzentrum Herr Bürgermeister
das war eine Zeit als das System beinahe
zusammengebrochen ist und sehr
stellvertretender
Militärkommandant wir waren zur Stelle
das gesamte Bundesheer die Soldatinnen
und Soldaten waren zur Stelle das sind
nur einige dabei Beispiele ja und im
Jägerbataillon 33 das sind die Profis
für die militärische
Landesverteidigung genauso zu finden wie
die Fachleute für den Schutz kritischer
Infrastruktur die Grenzsicherung und die
Katastrophenhilfe
so viele angelobungen wenn nicht das
letzte wenn wir das letzte Jahr so Revue
passieren lassen haben nur direkt den
Kasernen stattfinden können mit einigen
wenigen geladenen Gästen oft ohne die
Angehörigen unserer Rekruten und daher
ist es mir persönlich und ich bin
überzeugt davon das geht ihnen allen
auch so eine ganz besonders große Freude
dass wir heute dabei sein können neben
dem Rahmenprogramm mit der Informations-
und geräteschaue dann auch endlich
wieder einmal
eine Aufführung des großen
österreichischen Zapfenstreiches zu
hören bekommen
157 junge Menschen des ABC abwehrzuges
und des Jägerbataillons 33 werden heute
angelobt
ein persönliches versprechen ein
persönliches Versprechen auf die
Republik Österreich und auf die
Demokratie das ist es dass sie heute
abgeben
sehr geehrte Angehörige unserer Rekruten
sehr geehrte Rekruten diese angelobungen
eine Angelobung ist ein bewegender
Moment für sie alle
denn mit diesem Gelöbnis übernehmen sie
vor allem eines
Verantwortung
Verantwortung für sich selbst für ihre
Kameraden
Verantwortung aber auch für die
Sicherheit unserer Republik Österreich
mir persönlich ist es bewusst und ihnen
selber auch
ihren Angehörigen ohne Zweifel dass das
eine neue Lebenssituation ist für Sie
sie haben ihre gewohnte Umgebung sie
haben ihre
Arbeitsstätte verlassen um ein halbes
Jahr den Dienst mit der Waffe zu
versehen
ich möchte Ihnen für diese Entscheidung
Danke sagen für diese Entscheidung dass
sie diese Wahl getroffen haben um ihren
Teil zur Sicherheit Österreichs und
seiner Bewohner zu leisten
ich möchte aber auch
Worte an die Angehörigen richten ich
möchte Ihnen versichern dass die
Ausbildungsverantwortlichen undoffiziere
und Offiziere alles daran setzen werden
dass ihre Söhne nach ihrem Dienst wieder
wohlbehalten nach Hause zurückkehren
jetzt noch einige Worte auch an die
Anwesenden Entscheidungsträger aus
Politik aber auch aus der Gesellschaft
ich bitte Sie
unterstützen Sie nicht nur bei
Veranstaltungen wie den heutigen bei
ehrwürdigen Veranstaltungen und
Festakten wie dem heutigen das
Bundesheer sondern tun sie das jeder und
jede auch in ihrem eigenen
Wirkungsbereich unser Bundesheer unsere
Soldatinnen und Soldaten insbesondere
unsere Grundwehrdiener die heute hier
vor Ihnen stehen die brauchen vor uns
stehen die brauchen ihre Unterstützung
auch dann wenn es darum geht Interessen
des österreichischen Bundesheeres seiner
Soldaten in der Öffentlichkeit zu
vertreten
meine Damen und Herren Rekruten
Angehörige sie alle wissen es am besten
die Landesverteidigung die ist ja in
Wahrheit im Alltag aller
Österreicherinnen und Österreicher
irgendwann einmal ein Thema durch die
allgemeine Wehrpflicht durch das
stellungswesen durch die Frage auch ob
jemand tauglich ist oder nicht davon
sind in Wahrheit alle österreichischen
Familien irgendwann einmal betroffen
um unseren Grundwehrdienern und das ist
unser aller Ziel auch die beste
Ausbildung zu ermöglichen haben wir
heuer mit dem Modell mein Dienst für
Österreich glaube ich einen sehr
wichtigen Schritt gesetzt es gibt die
Möglichkeit für die Grundwerte Ihnen
nach der sechs Monaten Grundausbildung
freiwillig ein paar Monate in Form eines
funktionsdienstes anzuhängen und ich
sage an dieser Stelle schon ich wünsche
mir dieses auch wir brauchen das auch
damit wir insbesondere in der
Kernkompetenz des Bundesheeres der
Landesverteidigung trainiert werden und
trainieren können
unsere Grundwehrdiener und das wird
vielleicht das eine oder andere Mal auch
vergessen und daher sei es genau an
diesem Tag und in diesem Moment
angesprochen sie sind die Basis sie sind
die Basis unseres Heeres die Basis des
österreichischen Bundesheeres denn ohne
Grundwehrdiener gibt es keine
Kadersoldaten ohne Grundwehrdiener gibt
es auch keine Miliz
und unsere Soldatinnen und Soldaten sie
haben sich auch die beste Ausrüstung
verdient
schlechter hat schon angesprochen wir
haben einige Schritte schon gesetzt aber
wir haben ohne Zweifel noch viele vor
uns wir müssen investieren für ein
modernes für ein
zukunftsträchtiges Bundesheer und das
werden wir insbesondere auch hier in
Niederösterreich tun in die
Infrastruktur wir müssen 60 Bauvorhaben
in nächster Zeit Umsetzen von der
Nasszelle bis zur Generalsanierung ist
es notwendig unsere Kasernen auch auf
Vordermann zu bringen wir werden auch
unsere fliegerische Truppe aufstützen
und ohne Zweifel wird auch die
Katastrophenhilfe ein wesentlicher
Einsatzbereich sein wir werden das
Bundesheer so aufstellen dass wir in
Zukunft gemeinsam mit dem
Blaulichtorganisationen auch andere
Szenarien und Herausforderungen des 21
nächsten Jahrhunderts bewältigen können
ich denke sie alle wissen wovon ich
spreche es ist keine Frage ob ein
Blackout Eintritt sondern eigentlich nur
die Frage wann
ein Blackout Eintritt und darauf haben
wir uns vorzubereiten mit autarken
Kasernen um rasch und effizient auch
reagieren zu können das ist unsere
Aufgabe dass es unsere Verantwortung und
auch in der tabsk-kaserne in Korneuburg
ist es notwendig in den nächsten Jahren
in die Infrastruktur in den Bereich der
Autarkie zu investieren
Soldatinnen Soldaten Rekruten
ich bedanke mich bei Ihnen ich bedanke
mich bei Ihnen für ihre
Einsatzbereitschaft für ihre
Einsatzbereitschaft unsere Heimat zu
schützen unseren Staat Österreich zu
schützen unsere Bevölkerung zu schützen
Demokratie und Neutralität uns alle zu
schützen
unser Herr das österreichische
Bundesheer das ist dafür die
Sicherheitsgarantie
Ihnen den Rekruten die heute hier
Gelöbnis ablegen wünsche ich vor allem
eines eine interessante eine lehrreiche
Dienstzeit beim österreichischen
Bundesheer ich wünsche Ihnen für Ihre
jeweilige Aufgabe alles Gute Erfolg und
Soldaten Glück und denken Sie an die
vielen Möglichkeiten die Ihnen das
österreichische Bundesheer auch als
Dienstgeber bieten kann
es lebe das österreichische Bundesheer
es lebe die Republik Österreich
es erfolgt nun das Treuegelöbnis danach
hören Sie Landeshymne
das ganze
[Musik]
eingeteilter Rekruten
Rekruten zum Gewehr
Rekruten auf mein Kommando ich gelobe
mein Vaterland
die Republik Österreich
und sein Volk zu schützen
und mit der Waffe zu verteidigen
ich gelobe
den Gesetz und den gesetzmäßigen
Behörden
[Applaus]
Treue und Gehorsam zu leisten
alle Befehle meiner Vorgesetzten
[Applaus]
pünktlich und genau zu befolgen
und mit all meinen Kräften
der Republik Österreich
und dem österreichischen Volk
[Applaus]
zu dienen
eingeteilte Rekruten eintreten
das ganze Parade
schon
niederösterreichischen Landeshymne das
ganze recht Shop
[Musik]
das ganze hopp
ehrenzug schon
ehrenzug beim Fuß
das ganze Parade Ruth der kommandantste
DR Gerald Bauer bietet nun um weitere
Befehle und die kommen damit zum zweiten
Höhepunkt dieses Festaktes dem großen
österreichischen Zapfenstreich
das ganze
[Musik]
schon
ehrenzug pressen
das ganze regt Stopp
wir bauen meldet die Beendigung der
feierlichen Angelobung unterbietet den
Befehl zum umgruppieren für den großen
Österreich
zum großen österreichischen
das ganze
schon
[Musik]
das ganze Parade
während die Militärmusik
Niederösterreich unter der Leitung von
Oberst Magister Adolf obendrauf nun die
Aufstellung verändert möchte ich die
Gelegenheit nutzen Ihnen etwas über
dieses Musikstück zu erzählen
seit dem frühen Mittelalter wurde der
Beginn der Nachtruhe in den herlagern
durch ein trommelsignal den sogenannten
Zapfenstreich angekündigt man nimmt an
das mit diesem Signal der Marketender
den Zapfen des junkfases hineinschlagen
also streichen musste um so den
Ausschank zu beenden zu Beginn des 18
Jahrhunderts als diese herlage immer
größer wurden marschierten Feld oder
lagermusiken durch die Lager und
kündigten die Nachtruhe mit einem
Musikstück dem alten Zapfenstreich an
begleitet wurde die Musik von der Wache
um die Einhaltung der Nachtruhe
sicherzustellen erst später als in die
Termin hornsignale eingeführt wurden
übereinander die Aufgabe die Nachtruhe
anzukündigen im Verlauf viele Jahrzehnte
entstand daraus immer mehr Zeremoniell
dass sie schließlich zum großen
Zapfenstreich entwickelte er besteht aus
drei Teilen und ich darf sie ja suchen
wenn sie klatschen möchten das bitte
erst am Ende zu tun
eingeleitet durch eine Fanfare stellt
der erste teilmusikalisch der aus der
Ferne kommende lagermusik da welche das
eigentliche Signal zur Nachtruhe den
Zapfenstreich zuerst den historischer
und anschließend in zeitgemäßen
Instrumentierung spielt danach
erscheinen in der Reihenfolge die
hornsignale für Haupt 8 vergatterung
Sturm Beschleunigung und Attacke
gespielt gibt es von zwei Trompetern und
nach einem trommelstreich noch einmal
der Zapfenstreich die traditionsmärsche
bringt zwar gehen und Udo wenn
Österreich beenden diesen ersten Teil
danach kommt der zweite religiöse teil
welche mit dem trommelstreich zum Gebet
eingeleitet wird dem niederländischen
Dankgebet einem Hornsignal und dem
orchestralen Gebiet folgt das Gebet
während der Schlacht
Zapfenstreich leitet schließlich auf das
Vorspiel zur Bundeshymne und somit zum
dritten Teil über ist er gegen die
Bundeshymne und mit dem abblasen durch
den solothompeter und dem Abschlagen des
Zapfenstreiches ist dieses feierliche
Musikstück beendet mit der Meldung der
Beendigung des Zapfenstreiches und dem
Ausmarsch endet dieser Festakt
das ganze top
ehrenzug schon
das ganze recht Shop
das ganze
ehrenzug schon
beim Fuß
das ganze Parade
[Musik]
das ganze
hab acht
das Ganze zum Gebet
[Musik]
das ganze vom Gebet
das ganze Parade Ruth
[Musik]
Flagge wiederholen
zum niederholder Flagge das ganze recht
Shop
[Musik]
das ganze
schon
[Musik]
beim Fuß
das ganze Parade Ruth
[Musik]
[Applaus]
schon
Bundesminister das ganze recht Shop
die Beendigung des großen
österreichischen pfaffenstreichs
[Musik]
ehrenzug beim Fuß
das ganze Parade Ruth
militärmusik